[Música]
y
sentate cállate no hables no preguntes
no digas nada no vayas no se puede es
peligroso
estos son los comentarios que escuchamos
en nuestro hogar o en nuestra escuela en
nuestra comunidad muchos temores y
restricciones yo doy gracias a que
siempre tenía unas corrientes de
rebeldía y audacia fluyendo en línea que
me animaron a salir de casa con tan solo
17 años y sin pedir permiso
el 2006 a pesar de los temores de mi
familia salí de bolivia y me fui a vivir
a canadá allí cursó dos años de
secundaria junto a 200 estudiantes de
todos los continentes áfrica asia
oceanía europa el medio oriente
norteamérica latinoamérica
cada día lejos de mi hogar pero en este
ambiente tan diverso fue desafiante y
también muy enriquecedora
a partir de esa vivencia despertó en mí
una curiosidad por el mundo y una sed
incansable de aventura
y me di cuenta que nuestras asociadas
son complejas y que hay mucho por
explorar desde entonces han pasado 13
años y he recorrido más de 20 países
desde escocia hasta hungría desde
trinidad y tobago el caribe hasta el sur
de chile y lugares más remotos como
emiratos árabe y las islas fiji un lugar
en el pacifico si es que alguien puede
apuntarlo ya en el mapa
la ayuda que les voy a compartir es que
viajar es un mecanismo para descubrir
nuestras capacidades de manera acelerada
viajar nos coloca en situaciones
desafiantes y requiere que estemos más
alertas para navegar por lo desconocido
durante el proceso de adaptarnos a los
cambios nos vemos forzados a desarrollar
nuestras capacidades para poder salir
adelante
en cambio si nos quedamos en nuestras
casas como tranquilos no hay una fuerza
que impulse nuestro cambio
en mi caso viajando descubrí cuatro
capacidades
cuatro capacidades que las uso todos los
días para enfrentar mis dificultades
cuatro capacidades que han sido
fundamentales para mi crecimiento
cuatro capacidades que me ayudan a
enfrentar mis problemas de manera
brillante y audaz
durante un viaje llegamos a un lugar
nuevo nos encontramos con creencias y
costumbres a las que no estamos
acostumbrados nos sentimos abrumados nos
queremos aferrar a lo que conocemos
qué hacemos para abrirnos a nuevas
experiencias
antes yo he evitado utilizar el
transporte público de mi ciudad natal
santa cruz de la sierra veía a los
micros pasar repletos de gente y
recorrer las calles de manera
descontrolada
me parecía cómodo incómodo peligroso sin
embargo durante los viajes el transporte
público muchas veces es la única opción
lo tuve que usar mucho y lo que vi me
sorprendió
en canadá los buses tenían una
plataforma que se inclinaba a recoger a
las personas en silla de ruedas
en fiji los buses no tenían vidrios en
las ventanas y entraba la brisa marina
mientras el conductor amenizada con
música reggae
en alemania los trenes salían a horas
exactas o si 31 527 y por eso nos
sorprende que haya perdido el transporte
muchas veces
en hungría el transporte público incluye
una lancha para cruzar el río danubio de
una orilla que se llamaba muda a la otra
orilla que se llamaba peso y así
inventaré porque se llama buró testing
ahora me encanta utilizar el transporte
público siento que es como echar un
vistazo a la cultura local así que al
retornar a bolivia volví a utilizar los
micros y también pero hay muchos
aspectos que podemos mejorar el servicio
a través de esas vivencias descubrí una
primera capacidad nosotros podemos
ampliar nuestra perspectiva
si tenemos un punto de vista muy
limitado sufrimos el riesgo de anclar
nos a prejuicios y parcialidades
en cambio si ampliamos nuestra
perspectiva observamos distintos
entornos podemos abrirnos a nuevas
experiencias de aprendizaje las nuevas
oportunidades
durante un viaje no todo sale como
planificado que hacemos si llegamos a
nuestro lugar de destino y nos
encontramos con algo inesperado
el 2015 estaba visitando barcelona con
mi amigo pascal un alemán alto rubio y
experto mochilero digamos a las afueras
de la iglesia sagrada familia- un punto
icónico de la ciudad pero
las puertas estaban cerradas las luces
estaban apagadas y había poca gente
alrededor
yo tímidamente no podemos entrar esta
sierra mejor vámonos
pascal superpráctico confiado dijo mai
nai nine yo quiero entrar de alguna
manera
voy a buscar como
bueno en la esquina pascal encontró un
afiche que decía que había misa en la
iglesia en 30 minutos y el ingreso era
gratuito
es así que pudimos ingresar asistir al
servicio religioso y desde adentro
admirar la obra maestra de gaudí
esa tarde descubrí una segunda capacidad
nosotros podemos tomar el mando de
nuestra historia
si hubiera aferrado a esa narrativa
pesimista de uno no se puede
no hubiera tenido esa hermosa
experiencia en cambio si optamos por la
narrativa optimista de yo quiero como
seas nos abrimos a nuevas experiencias y
podemos lograr lo que queremos
durante un viaje los recursos son
limitados muchas veces lo único con lo
que contamos es lo que cabe en nuestra
pequeña maleta
qué hacemos si no encontramos lo que
necesitamos
el 2013 que siempre había mudado
amarillo alagoas en brasil y tenía
dificultad encontrando vivienda donde
voy a vivir era muy caro había poca
oferta y muchos requisitos de
documentación
hace varias semanas preocupadas y
recurrí a mis amigos de la universidad
katy mía mía peruana me hice quieres ya
pero venía a vivir con nosotros pues
vivimos
ellos eran tres estudiantes que ya
compartían un departamento con tres
cuartos nosotros éramos cuatro personas
que hicimos
bueno la sala de estar la transformamos
en la cuarta habitación instalamos un
ropero que servía para guardar cosas
dividir ambiente colocamos una cortina
que servía de puerta compramos un sofá
cama y importante nos sentamos a definir
las reglas de convivencia luces apagadas
a las 11 prohibido invitados después de
las 10
es así que viví nueve meses en una cama
pero pude compartir lindos momentos con
mis amigos pude ahorrar y pude vivir a
cinco cuadras de una hermosa playa
turquesa
durante un viaje los cambios nos traen
estrés
sufrimos altibajos emocionales
qué hacemos si llega un momento de
frustración lo queremos dar todo por
perdido
y eso sentí el 2015 cuando llegue a la
estación del nuremberg en alemania tenía
tres horas antes de mi siguiente tren
bueno me abajo un día súper gris frío
cientos de personas entraban y salían a
la situación llegó a la puerta y me
congeló
no tenía batería de mi celular estaba
sola no tenía un mapa pensé no no oí
hasta el libre por ahí me pierdo mejor
me queda aquí adentro y espero el
siguiente tren
mientras temía ese debate interno me
dije pero voy a llevar nueve años
viajando y muchas veces sola
me acordé que había visto fotos del
castillo y era hermoso
no pues ese rato me acomodé los
pantalones reuní coraje y salí por la
puerta y ni saben
el casco histórico estaba al frente de
la estación de tren tan solo tuve que
cruzar la calle para ver el castillo
comerme todas las salchichas con hayward
típicas de alemania
y conocer esa nueva ciudad
esta tarde aprendí la cuarta capacidad y
tal vez la más importante
nosotros podemos acumular auto-confianza
si me hubiera dejado llevar por mis
temores no hubiera tenido ese momento
especial no hubiera conocido estando en
la ciudad
en cambio si utilizamos los recuerdos de
nuestros logros y conquistas como una
fuente de valor ante los próximos
desafíos
nunca partimos desde el punto cero
nuestros años hablan ya de un trayecto
recorrido un acumulativo positivo de
allí podemos sacar valor y confianza
para los siguientes momentos ahora
cuando sintamos esa frustración
pensemos ya hemos logrado cosas antes
aquella vez pudimos hoy toca intentarlo
para finalizar quiero comentarles que la
comunidad viajera es inmensa el 2018 la
organización mundial del turismo
registró 1.4 billones de viajeros
internacionales
los viajes pueden ser para vivir
trabajar ejemplo pasantías
internacionales para estudiar programas
de becas cursos de idiomas voluntariado
intercambios culturales
simplemente para visitar
los viajes también pueden ser aquí
dentro de nuestro país a otras ciudades
a otras provincias al carnaval de oruro
a la reserva natural de toro toro o las
serranías de santiago de chiquitos
pero todos los viajes son oportunidad
para salir de casa aventurarse sacar es
una selva y con edificios famosos y
descubrir nuestras capacidades
darnos cuenta que nosotros podemos
acumular auto-confianza buscar recursos
de manera creativa tomar el mando de
nuestra historia y ampliar nuestra
perspectiva
les aseguro que cuando volvemos a casa
estas nuevas capacidades que tenemos con
nosotros nos ayudan en nuestra vida
personal y profesional entrevistas citas
emprendimientos
por eso hoy quiero hacer el llamado a la
acción a que se unan a la gran comunidad
de viajeros a que busquen sus maneras de
ser brillantes y audaz y en su próxima
aventura
cuáles de sus capacidades van a
descubrir
obrigado the new jersey new crime su
cría daniel bad expansiva guns 'n'
unidad domo arigato gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]